so much has happened since I saw you I
lost Miami like yesterday so that's
still pretty fresh
and then I went on a journey of
self-discovery I love you
you
[Music]
Wow you have no idea
hello the goddess of death has invaded
us god oh I miss this
and you and I had a fight which name did
I win
now I want easily since I'm right Oh
[Music]
as god is dead little be reborn in my
image
I thought you'd be glad to ceiling near
the stopper here now prevent riding rock
they end up everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
surprise this response funny
hi
these are fighter
and we go
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the God all again
[Music]
for the same unite just a couple of
hotheaded fools yes all kite fire door
like water
I can't pacify the whole clique raging
flood - I like smoldering fire holy crap
this is so awesome
we have Hulk vs Surtur Hulk vs Fenris
wolf in a whole bunch of hella just
ripping the [ __ ] out of everybody
there will be more comic-con stuff
happening be sure to subscribe to get it
and make sure you turn alerts on so you
don't miss the videos you know it's been
a long time since we met each other so
much has happened and I love the way
that he's talking to banner after their
big fight what would happen
did I win he gets his ass handed to him
by Hulk and says no no I beat you easily
but even though we don't see any real
actual infinity gem in this and I do
think there's infinity gem in the movie
they still show you all these different
realms you see a lot of Valkyrie on
Asgard she was one of the Valkyries you
could see them spilling out of Asgard
like they're coming out of heaven this
is so beautiful it's straight out of a
painting they're coming down to her in
her realm as she attacks all of them
it's a way to show you how powerful she
is like she takes down all of these
characters coming at her then she
officially says I'm going to destroy
Asgard and remake it in my image we
hadn't really gotten that part before
but it's part of the idea of Ragnarok is
he you tear something down and something
new comes back in its place but all this
crazy cityscape you're seeing this is
all from Sekar and like we said in
previous trailers it's basically a junk
planet at the end of the universe so
it's sort of at the end of all these
different space waves where the
universes trash gets dumped so if you
remember during guardians of the galaxy
when there pinballing
all over the universe trying to get to
ego the Living Planet you have to
imagine that it's sort of like a maze
and at the end of that maze is the car
we're just all the [ __ ] that gets passed
through those gateways ends up getting
dumped eventually like the river of
trash ends here which is why everything
looks so cobbled together in colorful
which i think is to the benefit of the
movie but the other huge thing is we
finally get to see Hulk talk I thought
that was going to be the biggest thing
until they did the big server reveal
right after that like you're like oh my
god hook is finally talking hook like
fire hook like a rage yes you know I
like fire too just so much of them
hanging out so you see a lot of Hulk you
see a lot of banner but let me know what
you guys think of the new Hulk model
because obviously that's all CG and it
looks a little bit different from what
we've seen in previous movies I feel
like they've polished it a lot since
that first trailer dropped you see a
little bit more of scourge that's Carl
Urban's character he's something of an
antagonist but he follows hella
so we'll see if that happens to the
entire course of the movie or if it's
one of those situations where by hella
becomes so terrible releasing Firelord
Serdar on the nine realms that he
decides to turn against her love the
low-key introduction hello everybody and
then he finally teams up with Thor the
way they explained their relationship is
that they've kind of given up on trying
to fight each other and they just do
their own thing like he recognizes that
Loki is never going to stop being Loki
in Thor is never going to stop being
Thor so while these extra Shanda like
these guards here this just seems like
the Collector's bodyguards even though
they look a lot like the Eternals
or even the Celestials there's just a
lot of that Jack Kirby baked into the
movie on a visual level but we do know
from guardians of the galaxy that the
Celestials do exist in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but not in the way
that you thought they did before but we
have Isan the searcher
we have ego the Living Planet so they
take many different forms Tessa Thompson
still has not said what it is that
drives her to go to Sekar but it seems
like some of these shots where she's in
this white Valkyrie armor here with the
other Valkyries that this might be from
a flashback or if she puts it back on
but in any case it just seems like she's
in self-imposed exile on Sekar like
she's been hiding out like she's somehow
in disgrace while she's off in this part
of the universe because for a big
portion of this film Thor's going to be
without his hammer which is very much
like the unworthy Thor even though
technically that's not what the movie is
doing so that might be a parallel for
Valerie's character where she just feels
unworthy but the crazy thing is that we
might actually be seeing a version of
rune King Thor or Thor force Thor like
he's taken the odinforce into himself at
the end of the movie when it looks like
he's wielding the power of mule near
without the axe
we'll hammer itself like this is him on
a power level that we haven't seen
before so at some point in the film
either he's charged up by the odinforce
or a legit infinity gem but it looks
like it's straight out of Thor mythology
so whatever power was inside the hammer
is now directly inside him it just feels
like that could be infinity gem but it
could be something else but let me know
in the comments what do you think is up
with Thor force Thor at the end of the
movie here when he's going nuts on the
Rainbow Bridge without the hammer and if
you didn't know about Fire Lord Souter
he exists on a different realm all by
himself
it's adjacent to Hellas realm so on the
world tree they're like right down there
at the bottom next to each other but in
the grand sense of things he represents
the true Ragnarok when people say
they're going to destroy asgaard and
bring about Ragnarok he's the one with
the true power in the comics that
actually does that but what's going to
happen is there's a whole bunch more
Marvel stuff from the Marvel panel
they said that Captain Marvel the movie
is going to take place during the 90s
she will fight the scrolls they'll be
the big villain of the movie they were
talking about their other movies too so
I'll follow up with that in the next
couple of videos especially next week so
there'll be a lot of videos dropping
next week for stuff that I had to skip
this weekend because there's so much
other stuff but leave all your video
requests in the comments below while you
wait for everything you can click here
for a brand new Justice League trailer
and you can click here for the brand-new
flash trailer and all the other
comic-con stuff thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you